so i have the polynomial p of x here and
p of x is being expressed as a fourth
degree polynomial times three three x
minus eight squared so this would
actually give you some you know this
would give you nine
x squared and a bunch of other stuff and
then you multiply that times this it
would actually give you a sixth degree
polynomial all in all but our goal is to
find the x values where that makes p of
x equal to zero or another way find the
roots or the zeros of this polynomial in
particular we're going to focus on the
real zeros for the real roots of this
polynomial
and like always i encourage you to to
give a go at it and then and then we'll
do it together
all right let's let's tackle this so the
way i'm i want to solve p of x is equal
to zero i want to solve p of x is equal
to zero and figure out what and when i
say solve it i want to say well what x
values will make the polynomial equal to
zero so i just need to set this right
hand side to be equal to 0 and then
solve for x and the best way i can think
of doing that is by factoring this out
as much as i can and if i can if i can
rewrite it as a product of a bunch of
expressions equaling 0 well if you have
a product of a bunch of things equaling
zero you can make it equal zero by any
one of them equaling zero and so let's
do that so three x minus eight squared
this is already factored quite nicely
let's see if we can factor if we can
factor all this business in if we can
factor all of this business in white
and the way i will tackle it to see if i
can factor by grouping
so let me group together
these first two terms and then let me
group together
these second two terms and essentially
factoring by grouping is doing the
distributive property in reverse twice
so
from these first two terms i could
factor out
let's see what could i factor out i
could factor out a
let me see i'll just factor out an x to
the third power
so i get x to the third power times
3 x minus 8 interesting we had a 3x
minus 8 over there as well now these
second two terms
i could factor out a
5
so it's going to be plus 5
times x sorry times 3x
3x minus 8 very interesting and of
course
i have these parentheses around all of
that and then i have 3x minus 8
squared this 3x minus 8 is showing up a
lot
and so
and of course this is going to be equal
to 0
it's going to be equal to 0.
and now i can factor out a 3x minus 8
over here i could factor that 3x minus 8
out and i'm going to get
3 x minus 8
times
times
x to the third power
x to the third power plus 5 once again i
just factor out a 3x minus 8
plus 5
close the parentheses
and then times 3x minus 8 squared is all
going to be equal to 0
is all equal to 0. now if what i just
did looks a little bit like voodoo just
realize i have two terms both of them
are multiples of 3x minus 8. i just
factored out
i just factored out the 3x minus 8. i
did the distributive property in reverse
so i factored it out and what you're
left with this term you just left with
an x to the third and then this term
you're just left with a plus 5.
now i have 3x minus 8 times x to the
third plus 5
times 3x minus 8 squared well i could
just rewrite this as i have that's 3x
minus 8 to the third power times x to
the third plus 5. so let me do that so i
can just rewrite this as 3x minus 8 to
the third power that's that times that
and then times
times let me do this in a nicer color
times
x to the third
plus five
is equal to zero
is
equal to zero
and now in order to get this to be equal
0 either
either the 3x either this thing is going
to be equal to 0 or
or this thing over here is going to be
equal to 0. so let's first think about
3x minus 8
to the third power equaling zero
so i could write this as three x minus
eight
to the third power is equal to zero
or
or
x to the third plus five is equal to 0.
so to make 3x minus 8 to the third power
equals 0 well that means that 3x minus 8
is going to be equal to 0 or that 3x is
equal to 8 divide both sides by three x
is equal to eight thirds
so that's one way to make this
polynomial equal zero x is equal to
eight thirds in fact just this right
over here will become zero zero times
anything is zero
so this is a zero of our polynomial
and let's see so x to the third
so we could say if we subtract 5 from
both sides we have x to the third is
equal to the is equal to negative 5.
and so if we take both to the 1 3 power
we could say x is equal to the cube root
of negative 5. now at first you say hey
can i take a cube root of a negative
number and i would say of course you can
the cube root of negative 1 is negative
1. the cube root of negative 8 is
negative 2. in fact you could
even if we're dealing with reals this is
going to be a negative number this is
not going to be an imaginary number
right over here and so these are
these are the two
zeros of the polynomial there's going to
be negative i think negative one point
something actually we could figure out
it figured out exactly
so let's raise
so let's raise
that cube root on this note let's raise
five
to the
open parentheses one divided by 3
close parentheses is equal to
so that's 5 to the 1 3 so negative 5 to
the 1 3 power is going to be negative
1.71
approximately
so this is approximately equal to
negative
1.71
so we have two real roots two real roots
to this polynomial or two zeros two real
zeros for this polynomial and so those
are going to be the two places where we
intercept the x-axis the two x-values
for which where the two places where we
intercept the x-axis i guess is the
easiest way to say it